I am clearly the powerful psychic Mewtwo
right now
EB yeah yeah BV BV yeah and this is the
powerful of Mewtwo and V's never seen
and today we're watching the original
Pokemon movie
Eevee Strikes Back okay so a little bit
about my Pokemon experience growing up I
was not allowed to have pokemon cards I
had the first light bit and then my mom
decided that they were Pocket Monsters
and we were not allowed to have them so
she took my pokemon cards away and then
I remember one time like begging like oh
can we please watch the show she's like
let's watch an episode and see if it's
appropriate and then we got halfway
through and like a giant was a big like
oval black widow spiky bottom she showed
up and was like destroying the town and
mom was like no never and I was just
distraught with sadness I grew up
watching the show your friends houses or
after people went to bed or after my mom
like stopped caring as much but I never
saw the movie I remember seeing like
bits of it when I was younger but mom
was pretty
she was pretty controlling so we have a
new show coming out soon called $20
cosplay and it's with me Heather and
Ayanna and we did Pokemon trainers but
like as the Pokemon so Ayanna was
Charizard and Heather was squirtle and I
was Bulbasaur so that's coming out soon
so watch out for that alright let's do
it one two three
[Music]
we dreamed of creating the most powerful
Pokemon and we succeeded Who am I
what is air do bugs really exist are
these my three nerves
what are these nubs Who am I who are you
who am I Mewtwo is very contemplative in
this yeah like if he was voiced by like
Patrick Stewart or Ian McKellen it
wouldn't be out of place definitely I
don't know who voiced invoice was very
regal I really enjoyed his voice Who am
I just very sophisticated versus the
rest of the cash swishing wine
swishing wine with his three nubs I
enjoyed him he was very pretty just all
purple and pastel and gorgeous a little
contemplative for for a movie such as
this I will say yeah they try to touch
on some deep things but they also
realize that children are watching this
and so they'll just say the thing
they're trying to they just say it that
just say like here brother hood shit
friends that is what they said will
spell it out for you Brotherhood shit
they have all these themes throughout
the film and then at the very end
they're like just in case you didn't get
here's actually Oh together so the movie
starts off and Mewtwo learns that he's
been created and cloned by mu and he's
like what my boys my business is true
potently real and like just very very
contemplative very upset with how he's
been cloned and decides that he's gonna
go off and be this all-powerful being
again there's like stretch get rid of um
all of the humans at the Pokemon who
have decided to be
ruled by humans and he learns a bunch of
stuff from ravioli Giovanni yeah and
yeah yeah then then pulls like an Agatha
Christie and then there were none and
it's like I am this rich pokemon trainer
come to my loftiest state and it was
like Oh mysterious and then they show up
but it's just meat you know yeah there's
like kind of a mystery elements like
weirdness joy go where she at
who is this mystery woman who could it
be
she's so deadpan miss nurse joy as
mystery woman is so a deadpan come on
over but I know you died so canon its
mystery woman because of the subtitles
yeah every lie she says it's like my
master would like to see you let us go
this way like sure it's because she's
being mind-controlled by the psychic
from youtube but it's hilarious
nonetheless her name is mystery woman
and she had some history no person I
wrote Mewtwo says humans may have made
me but they will never enslave me nice I
was not born a Pokemon I was created
she's just putting youtuber instead of
that I could I feel that very much
YouTube may have made me they will never
enslave me I was not born at youtuber I
was created Oh rifts one socket first
action and misty and Brock are there
with all the pokemons and there they're
eating there no shoes - and then this
random guy comes up it was like let's
battle or no ash let's notice and then
this amazing version of the Pokemon song
comes on but the riffs are out of this
world every word that can be ripped is
ripped Italy among think it's not just a
weak irregular like uh it's like I love
elaborate he gets a piece like
all the music in this movie is so
intense and amazing they were like let's
take it to the next level let's just
pump it up to 11 yeah Team Rocket shows
up I really want to do a Team Rocket
cosplay with you I think I'll be really
fine magic they don't make very much
sense of this movie
ya know normally to have a bit more like
they're part of it more they follow
along they have an impact on the story
more and this one there's kind of there
there's kind of show up is like oh who
are you dude they like cowering on the
sidelines the whole time you know
there's no like you said there's no real
arc to their story at all there's just
there because they kind of have to be
there but they're but not the villains
and yeah it doesn't make sense for them
to be there really but I do want to have
their outfits yeah I love that middle
America joke because like let me know
Vikings still existed yeah they mostly
live in Minnesota marcozzi I'm only the
best of the best Pokemon trainers makes
it to this island because he Meucci
makes this giant storm and how we know
he made this giant storm is he takes his
three little prong two fingers and goes
like this and all you see is just an
image of this like this hand only and
then you see some clouds start to form
but you get like a solid minute
just the three per month and then they
all start to battle and then he's like
well I'm gonna make clones of you all
and he makes clones of them all and then
then they start to battle the clones of
the poky so like Pichu Oh Pikachu
they're the heroes and they all they're
fighting each other and then this song
comes on about how brother Otis more
brothers and it's really slow paced and
so the killer ography looks like they're
kind of dancing but they're actually
fighting each other there's just one
sequence where Pikachu's just slapping
this shit out of the other
but it's slowed me up eh you're just
looking at it in the eyes like the pika
can't deal with the moral ambiguity of
its actions finally after all this has
happened you're like how is this
possibly gonna write itself
right this wrong and then you shows up
so I'll turn and sub me yells out so
Neil Jewish clone from you and
everyone's like everyone look like
Gyarados what how could we have known we
never would have I don't know there's no
sign check the Pikachu for that one yeah
I love also when Mew and Mewtwo meet up
with each other
Mewtwo is like just hard for monologuing
like villain monologue E and mu is just
like the same bloody we are we must see
who is more right nurse Joy's like
Pokemon aren't meant to fight fabulous
yeah it's like Buddha bond with the bite
yeah they are yeah they are yeah they
are in our story I guess she's saying
like there s was a fight like each other
like this on properly did I guess so ash
turns to stone yeah cuz he's like stop
fighting and there's a blast she's like
there's like a mean it's like top is
like what's the saddest moment
really yeah ahaha I mean yeah was
effective for sure and then all of the
pokemon tears they all discovered that
they've been so wrong well we've been
fighting for what we're brothers
we gotta end this war with art with each
others they all start crying and some of
the Pokemon are hilarious some of them
can emot-- really side up yeah so so
yeah some of Pokemon of emotions
some of them squirtle has emotions
squirrel does other ones doing oh no it
wasn't Ivysaur it was a penis or penis
or this penis or was so dead inside yeah
just dead inside for fighting his
brother so he's just like oh I'm a
Gyarados is like just same expression
but just tears are coming down
yeah like Blastoise he's just generally
got a built-in smirks Oh tears back
which yeah they'll float in the middle I
turn a bag in the flesh and blood like
like real life then you to like floats
off and starts to leave and it's like
I'm gonna go learn what you already know
so well how to use my heart and then
they're all transported back to before
they went to the island and they forget
everything so all the lessons right time
basically all the lessons learned now
we're just gone yeah it's like hey
nothing happened it was cute it felt
like just a longer episode yeah yeah
nothing hands wrong and like early 90s
animation style like hand-drawn anime
yeah yeah since I've seen Acura anything
else I see like hand-drawn just is like
lackluster in comparison cuz it's such
fine detail I'm like yeah it's a nice
ocean mountain scene but like can I see
every piece of grass no now I checked
and it made me really excited to watch -
check - Pikachu made me really excited
for the $20 cosplay pokemon trainer
episodes come out episode that's worth
absolutely and it was fun it was also an
hour and 17 minutes which oh well thank
you for joining me we will see you
tomorrow with detective Pikachu
[Music]
alright let's go I'm gonna make some
lazy boy no juice too
[Music]
[Applause]
you